well joining me now is Indiana
Congressman Jim Banks and Florida
Congressman Byron Donald gentlemen Beau
thank you very much for being here so
Congressman Banks
let's just say ask it Point Blank our
shift and swalwell threats to our
national security
without a doubt uh remember I'm the guy
that Nancy Pelosi kicked off of the fake
sham January 6 committee last year she
never gave a single reason why she
kicked me off the committee and here you
have speaker McCarthy a man of his word
he followed through on a promise that he
made that he would he would not let
these two threats to our national
security serve on the intelligence
committee never mind that being on the
intelligence committee implies that
you're intelligent and we're talking
about the two of the biggest clowns in
Congress uh swalwell taking the cake
obviously I mean caught think about it
caught in a very compromising situation
this guy shouldn't be allowed anywhere
near our national Secrets because of how
compromised he was today Mike Pompeo
confirmed that Adam Schiff actually
released knowingly released classified
information when he was chair of course
of the intelligence committee he
shouldn't be allowed on the committee
after doing that he should be punished
for it so kudos to speaker McCarthy for
following through and what he said he
would do neither of these two guys
should even be in Congress let alone
serving on the intelligence committee
yeah no one leaked more than Schiff uh
and that's public knowledge whether
you're you follow the news or you're in
inside the Beltway he would walk out of
those briefings and hand it over to
Friendly media representative Donald
here's the thing swallow was so so
concerned about China excuse me a chef
was so con concerned about China he went
to Tick-Tock which may or may not be
owned by the CCP to fundraise right
after this happened watch this
we knew it would be bad when the
Republicans took over but it's far worse
than we expected but I can promise you
this this is not the end of my fight for
our democracy this is just the beginning
please join us and contribute today
the Chinese Tick Tock defense
representative Donald
well look I don't know where he's trying
to ask for campaign contributions but
let me just say this in terms of
fighting for the Democracy that has been
Republicans throughout this entire time
all we have wanted is the truth
surrounding all of these issues and what
we've known for quite some time is that
Adam Schiff has been leaking to the
Press leaking classified information all
to score political points with the
radical left in our country targeting
his political opponents on purpose and
using his seat on the intelligence
committee as chairman to do that if
you're going to go through and do
something like that and everybody on
Capitol Hill knows you don't get to
serve on the intelligence committee so
he can go raise all the money he wants
trust me that political fight will be
waiting for him right here and we're
going to win it because the truth has
finally prevailed and we're going to
take this Congress actually make sure
more of the facts more of the evidence
comes out to demonstrate to the people
what has actually happened on Capitol
Hill over the last couple of years
representative Banks uh there was
another member of Congress at that press
conference uh uh Omar uh was there ilhan
Omar was at the briefing uh here's what
she said listen Republicans have been
gunning for our seats
um and obviously know how effective that
we have been in upholding
the constitution in defending our
democracy and standing up to extremists
and we will continue to do that work
so ilhan Omar known anti-semite on the
house Foreign Affairs committee but yet
her position requires a majority vote to
kick her off the committee you have a
republican uh you have a majority
representative Banks do you think you
can do that
I hope so I'll be one of the first to
vote to remove her from the Foreign
Affairs committee remember she is one of
the most anti-israel members of Congress
maybe that Congress has ever seen uh I
mean her rhetoric against Israel is
dangerous Israel is our most important
Ally around the world especially at a
time like this where the Biden
Administration has turned the world
upside down and made the world a less a
far less safe place a more dangerous
place so to have a member of the Foreign
Affairs committee which is a committee
that's supposed to go out and help us
build relationships with our allies be
very anti-israel it's it's dangerous
ever on the committee to begin with so I
hope we vote to remove her I'll be one
of the first to cast my vote to do so
representative Donald you were in the
middle of the speakership fight uh what
is the not that this vote is The
Telltale sign but what is the what's the
the pulse of the caucus right now and
can they hang together on tight votes
like ilhan Omar
oh I firmly believe we're going to hang
together I agree with my colleague I'll
be the second vote uh when it comes to
Elon Omar uh look as a republican
conference we went through our
machinations but it was all about the
Republic it was about what House
Republicans are going to do to fulfill
all the promises we've made when we
campaigned to have a majority we have it
now and I fully believe in all my
conversations with my colleagues
throughout the conference we are going
to get the job done whether that's Adam
Schiff and swalwell and Elon Omar
whether it's the debt ceiling or
whatever else is to come securing our
border is one in particular we're going
to get the job done on behalf of the
American people
man I heard I sure hope so gentlemen
both of you thank you very much for
joining us tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else